[Applause]
[Music]
different swish politic aren't sure I
don't need to do much to convince you
that Latin America is one of the most
unsafe and volatile regions in the world
[Music]
unfortunately violence and crime have
made some latin-american areas very
dangerous as you may know we're talking
about a region that has been strongly
infested with drug trafficking arms
trafficking and many other illegal
activities which have been executed
without the individual states having
been able to AH let's not fool ourselves
wanting to fix the situation
even though it may be hard to understand
many criminal groups have built
extremely close links with governments
and public institutions in the region in
some cases these groups are even able to
influence control and direct entire
governments here on visual politic we
recently talked about the case of
Central America but there's another
volatile country which we can't ignore
and it's one which has shot to the lead
in recent years and may yet become the
most dangerous country on the planet I
am of course talking about Nicolas
maduro's Venezuela this is not a new
story we've already talked on this
channel about how Venezuela is becoming
a narco dictatorship at a breakneck
speed but unfortunately that's not the
worst of it in today's Venezuela crime
and organized crime are so much a part
of the scenery that if crime decreases
it's not outlandish to conclude that are
simply fewer and fewer things to steal
almost 30,000 fatalities each year in a
country that is not at war a hundred and
thirty thousand violent deaths in the
last five years alone according to
release data is truly awful
[Music]
while strange is that as you can see on
the screen
both the known homicide rates and the
number of violent deaths began to
actually decrease in 2017
this is strange considering that the
country is worse than ever both
economically and socially don't you
think and I note something you might be
thinking most probably because of all
the emigration venezuela has experienced
recently more than four million people
have left hundreds and hundreds of
thousands millions of young people and
emigrated which has to have an effect on
the statistics in its value out of that
well yes and no it's a truly gray area
in this video we're going to talk about
the effects of crime in Venezuela we're
talking about institutionalized crime
which has largely been caused by the
government itself and we're also gonna
talk about how crime has reached such
high levels that it's no longer
profitable for common criminals to
commit crimes within Venezuela causing
many to seek better opportunities
outside
evil in power first of all we need to
set the scene little let's say we're in
a regular country it's not unusual for
the government to fight crime and focus
resources on persecuting the bats right
well in Venezuela it's not like that
here we finds the opposite the bad guys
govern take a look at this
Tareq Li Sami United States includes
Venezuelan Minister in the ten most
wanted list for international narco
traffic Spanish judge investigates half
of maderos government for
money-laundering from oil sales
surprised I bet you aren't especially if
you've been following visual politic for
a while you've probably seen our video
on how Venezuela has become a narco
state and in case you haven't I'm gonna
link to that in the description the
truth is that there's not much that can
surprise us anymore from Venezuela
except for maybe one thing how the chevy
ster regime has managed to monopolize
street crime Maduro calls for
ideological related groups to quote
defend peace yes that's right the
Venezuelan government has literally
thousands of paid criminals criminals
who in many cases have been armed by the
state itself to function as para
political groups for political
repression they're known as collectives
the collectives are groups that mobilize
at government's request especially when
the opposition protests then they move
around on motorcycles carrying long
weapons and shooting at everything that
moves with absolute impunity while the
police and the Bolivarian National Guard
watched them impassively in many cases
they even act together
[Applause]
in other words that's how Venezuela's
violence has been controlled by the
state not for the purpose of ending it
but to dominate and mobilize it against
opposing citizens no that's not the end
of it in addition to the deadly
collectives which is now how they're
popularly known the actual state
security forces
well so-called security act as true
criminals
[Music]
it's give you a better idea according to
the data provided by the UN almost 7,000
people lost their lives due to
resistance to Authority between January
2018 and May 2019 that is in just over a
year there were 7000 extrajudicial
executions 464 policemen are prosecuted
in Venezuela for extortion and
kidnappings basically in Venezuela crime
occurs at every level and that largely
explains why goes unpunished as well
when the police themselves are often
complicit it is in good news 92% of
homicides in Venezuela go unpunished and
we're not just saying that on this
channel even Michelle actually the UN
High Commissioner for Human Rights
described the situation in a report on
Venezuela as such my office has
continued to document possible
extrajudicial execution cases committed
by members of the special police forces
of the National Police FA yes only last
July the non-governmental organization
victim monitor identified 57 new cases
of alleged executions committed by FA es
members in Caracas Michelle Bachelet
and I don't think you can say even
though Nicolas Maduro often makes such
claims the ballet is part of some
international movements that is
hell-bent on persecuting the Bolivarian
regime given ballets leftist leanings is
actually pretty absurd to think that
and considering Venezuela's situation
the testimonies and information
documented by the UN seems to be on the
conservative side which isn't surprising
by the way and still there is more
along with the collective's and the
state security forces reprehensible
actions the current situation in
Venezuela has also multiplied the
incidents of small-scale crimes
what to mention the widespread
corruption that reigns throughout the
country nowadays in Venezuela to get
official documents passports or even to
get medical attention bribes are
indispensable
and this has two fundamental reasons on
the one hands we have poverty and
practically useless wages hyperinflation
has made local salaries grossly
insufficient the new minimum wage in
Venezuela is only enough to buy an egg
carton and therefore petty crime becomes
almost natural it's just a matter of
survival
when in need people take advantage and
try to get any money they can using the
lack of control and impunity in their
favor now something you might be saying
but Simon didn't you say before that
crime was decreasing it doesn't seem to
be the case with what you just described
so I mean well it may seem like a
contradiction but the truth is that yes
crime is decreasing and we're gonna tell
you why and listen up because there are
some curveballs coming sakhu la
responsabilidad Luis Rey Mia Mia is to
you
[Music]
why is crime stopped being profitable
basically its Venezuela's SAB cruel
reality things are so bad that the
crisis has even affected criminals or
Melander us as they're known in
Venezuela Venezuela murder rate dips
partly due to migration monitoring group
crisis in Venezuela reduces robberies
and assaults criminals no longer can
afford bullets yes think about for a
moment with 200,000 percent inflation
which is what the IMF forecasts for this
year what uses it to steal small things
if the value of the money you're going
to get for them will deteriorate almost
overnight what uses it do break into a
bank's safe if the bolivars inside are
worthless or what good is it to steal
cars or motorcycles if you won't be able
to get spare parts or afford to put gas
in them and if we add the immigration
factor well the equation is solved
[Music]
yes it may seem surreal and hard to
believe but the disaster that nicolas
maduro
is leading Venezuela into is causing
thousands of thousands of criminals to
look for new places to commit crimes the
result is that Venezuela is simply
exporting its crime
Maduro boosts the exit of criminals from
Venezuela it's true Venezuela is so bad
right now that even criminals don't want
to stay and you know who the main
victims of this phenomenon are well yeah
it's the citizens of the country is
unfortunate to accept the criminals but
also do spare a thought for the other
three million non-criminal Venezuelans
you've emigrated as well here on visual
politic we can't avoid discussing the
effects that this phenomenon is having
on Venezuelan immigrants in the rest of
Latin America because leaving your
country behind your family and on top of
that's everything you've worked for was
already traumatic enough what if what
comes next is even more so difficult
condition of being Venezuelan in Latin
America that's right for many being
Venezuelan has become a challenge in
some Latin American countries can you
imagine what it's like to have to endure
constant racist or xenophobic comments
or suffer abuses from the authorities
just because you come from a specific
country well all of this stems from
Venezuelan criminals leaving for
neighboring countries
[Music]
this is how the lives of many Venezuelan
immigrants who do follow the rules which
is the vast majority are becoming more
difficult because of the few and that
causes situations like this red tape and
xenophobic attacks against Venezuelans
in Latin America in Peru for example
we've recently seen even congressmen
such as Esther Saavedra hotly attacking
Venezuelans from Congress itself can
imagine running away from a dictatorship
from hunger and violence and receiving
such insults from public representatives
it must be rather hard wouldn't you
think fortunately this way of thinking
doesn't represent all Peruvians not at
all but hate speeches that pinpoint a
specific nationality they're always
pretty worrying and coming from a
country's Congress but even more sighs
and that's not the end of it even the
Ecuadorian presidents Lenin Moreno fell
into the grip of this campaign after a
pregnant woman was murdered by
Venezuelans good.or
announces the creation of brigades to
quote control Venezuelan immigrants so
what is really behind this hatred of
Venezuelans in Latin America well it's
got a lot to do with poor migratory
culture
traditionally most of these countries
haven't needed to receive migrants and
suddenly overnight there's a Venezuelan
exodus through the whole continent given
that context it doesn't seem far-fetched
that many people perceive this movement
with fear fear of something different
something that comes from the outside
and the consequences that it may have
and this is even happening in Colombia
has been as wellas neighbor its welcomes
the most Venezuelans more than a million
and a half since the great Venezuelan
crisis exploded between 2014 and 2015
its proximity and the fact that
emigrating from Venezuela to Colombia is
cheaper has led many common Venezuelan
criminals to setting themselves up in
the country at first the Colombian
government's attitude aims to help the
Venezuelan population by opening its
borders granting temporary permits and
accepting Venezuelans with expired
passport
however this wave of solidarity at an
institutional level hasn't always
repeated at a street level in everyday
life since Colombia joins Peru Mexico
Chile Ecuador amongst the other
countries with most extreme cases of
xenophobia reported by Venezuelans
and when we talk about xenophobia we
mean things like this Venezuelans in
Colombia targeted by threatening
pamphlets of course this is by no means
the majority and if Latin American
societies have shown us anything it's a
huge solidarity to welcome thousands and
thousands hundreds of thousands of
Venezuelans who've been forced to flee
their country yes
criminals must be prosecutors but it
wouldn't be fair for the innocent to pay
for the sins of sinners would it what's
more these type of xenophobic outbreaks
favor the Venezuelan narco dictatorship
as they reduce the pressure on the
regime itself
anyway this is the reality of violence
in Venezuela ins all these factors
explain why this country has become a
true nightmare but now it's your turn
can violence be fought in a country
ruled by people who order criminals to
kill should Venezuelans broad-faced
their violent Patriots in order to end
xenophobia and what's even more
important do you think this hateful
behavior against them is actually
justified
well we ask the questions you provide
the answers so I already hope you
enjoyed this video please do hit that
like button if you did and don't forget
to subscribe for brand new videos also
please do check out our friends at
reconsider media they provided the
vocals in this episode that were not
mine also this channel is possible
because of patreon and our patrons on
that platform please consider joining
them and supporting us in our mission of
providing independent political coverage
and as always see in the next video
Karim okay boy 157 is finally
[Music]